موضوع المراه في افغانستان ايضا موضوع
حساس حرمانها من الدراسه حرمانها من
التعليم ومن العمل لكم اي دور على هذا
الصعيد
لقد عبرنا عن قلقنا بعد القرارات التي
اتخذت في اعقاب شهر ديسمبر من العام
الماضي وما قمنا به هو اننا تعاونا مع
السلطات في افغانستان لضمان ان كافه
الموظفات يمكن لهن ان تواصلنا عملهن كما
فعلتنا من قبل وهذا ما هو عليه الحال ومن
جانب اخر نحن نحرس على ضمان ان في
المستشفيات التي ندعمها وان في
المدارس التدريب
الطبي التي نمولها ان يكون هناك نساء ايضا
يعملن في هذه المؤسسات لانهم هذا امر مهم
لمستقبل افغانستان كما انها مساله اساسيه
اذا راغبنا في وتعامل مع بطريقه تستند الى
الاحتياجات ليس الا في الكثير من الفتيات
والكبيرات السن لديهن احتياجات وهنا تحتاج
لمساعدات طبيه من قبل النساء اذا نحن
تعاوننا مع السلطات ونواصل ذلك لضمان ان
يظل
السلطات تتجاوب معكم
والاناره
الحوار الذي نجريه استطعنا ان نواصل العمل
مع كافه
موظفاتنا
يعملنا معنا حتى الان وقد شهدنا ايضا انه
قدر المستطاع فان في المستشفيات والقطاع
الصحي الامر لله زال كذلك وهذا من اقوم به
بطريقه اللجنه الدوليه
للصليب الاحمر نحن
نتبنى حوار بنا وسري مع كافه الاطراف
المعنيه وهذه طريقه عملنا في العالم باسره
نقوم بالعمل بشكل سري لضمان اننا نواصل
عملا الانساني وكذلك لنحمي قدر المستطاع
المدنيين